good evening ladies and gentlemen
my name is philip Howell I'm the chief
executive of Rathbone brothers and this
is our third joint debate with the
spectator so to tonight's debate ensued
the next president of the United States
v Hillary Clinton or Donald Trump Donald
Trump is the dream the apotheosis of the
type caster's vision of the ugly America
in fact he is not a misogynist he is a
perfect equal opportunity employer and
his conversation personally is a good
deal less coarse than mrs. Clinton's
half of this campaign is a self authored
attack video and himself but that
doesn't mean it's true
this is a contest between an unfeasible
personality and a candidate carrying a
great deal of ethical and legal baggage
this election is all about Donald Trump
and his radical unfitness to be
President of the United States it would
be a disaster for America and a disaster
for the world if somebody like Trump
were to be elected president
modern-day politicians tell two types of
lies the first is BS other lies are more
serious hillary tells both kinds of lies
when congress asked the FBI director
Louis Freeh have you ever experienced
anything like the FBI's experiences with
the Clintons free said actually I have
investigating organized crime in New
York City thus I am NOT the first to
liken Hillary to a career criminal we
have a someone in Hillary Clinton who
has the experience and the understanding
of foreign affairs and foreign diplomacy
she has met with leaders she hasn't met
with Vladimir Putin
she knows what he's all about let's be
open the Clinton group decided from the
start the legitimize parts of the
Elector is a sexist racist xenophobic
homophobic and morally deformed that's
near forty million people the system is
rigged and if you want to change vote
for Trump this is a reality TV show this
isn't The Apprentice you're fired okay
Trump is an extinction event for the
United States of America anybody who
says that election is rigged threatens
the Republic and the best thing that can
actually happen is that this man is
defeated on November the 8th and then he
can start Trump TV which is what he
really wants to do thank you
who you thinks gonna win what you think
Clinton's gonna win the polls say she's
going to win anything could happen to
the Trump side think mr. Trump is going
to win tack it you don't okay that's
honest
are you comfortable Conrad black that
you are supporting a candidate that both
state about sexual attacks on women no
the fact is I have known even socially
for a long time
he doesn't talk like that and he doesn't
act like that which candidates most
likely to start a war by far Hillary
Trump is more of an isolation by far he
may have something to do with the Middle
East in a sense I agree with tacky I
think she will take a tougher line in
the Middle East and that is that that is
a risky course it is not possible to
imagine either candidate winning until
you consider the alternative I hope
you've enjoyed the forensic examination
of macroeconomic policy geopolitics and
all the rest of it on the way in you
voted 274 for mrs. Clinton 69 for mr.
Trump a hundred and eighteen undecided
having had the vote you have now voted
308 for mrs. Clinton 111 for Donald
Trump and 52 are still undecided if it
was up to this Hall Hillary Rodham
Clinton will be the next president of
the United States
please a big round of applause for our
great debaters